okay I'm just filming my eye with a
super macro lens so really close up
we're going to see if we can see
movement inside my eyeball let's get the
hot lights on
this was shot a thousand frames a second
which is 40 times slower and when I was
playing this back I noticed something
really weird something I've never seen
before and that is that the iris in my
eye which is the color part is actually
really loose it wobbles around as though
it's jelly so I was sort of making small
adjustments with my eye twitching it
around looking at different stuff and
every time I I stopped the iris sort of
carried on and then sort of wobbled
around until it stopped as well but it's
just I've never seen that before I'm not
I'm not sure whether everyone's eye does
this in slow-mo or whether I've got some
sort of eye condition may be some
opticians out there can let me know but
I thought it was really cool to look at
you have to excuse the vein illness of
my eye I hadn't had much sleep before we
film this some of the footage has been
sped up because even though I could only
keep my eye open for about five seconds
it's still added up to minutes worth of
urge that I don't want to bore you too
much
hello I'm announcing something we've
never done before we're actually going
to start doing a day course where you
can come down to our studio in Oxford
which is where we film will be indoor
episodes of the slow mo guys including
the eyeball one what you just watched
and you can learn the basics of high
speed it'll just be like an introduction
day to slow mo like what you need to be
able to shoot in slow-mo and stuff like
that you'll be able to use our famous
phantom flicks a slow-motion camera
which are extremely expensive and rare
and you'll maybe be able to shoot some
of your own ideas and take away some of
the footage at the end to show your
friends put on face book whatever you
want to do and yeah it'll be a fun day
will be educational as well and it's run
by myself and one of my colleagues who
is an expert in high-speed been doing it
for many years yeah I think it'd be fun
if you're interested it will cost two
hundred and fifty pounds for the day so
if you want to get involved have a
little think about it send an email to
slowmode day at gmail.com and we'll send
you more information and a booking form
yeah that's pretty much it I think I
covered everything yeah something to
think about
see in the next video
[Music]
you